One of the really sad and tragic things that
too often happens in bad situations is that
grifters come out of the woodwork with new
griffths that target exactly the most vulnerable
people at any particular time.
In this case, with the Corona virus, some
of the most vulnerable people are older folks
often who watch for.
News often who watched televangelist Christian
TV.
Now, I already told you last week how this
Christian lunatic, Jim Baker, was told by
the New York attorney general, stop promoting
this bogus silver solution cure for a corona
virus.
It's not a cure.
It can be harmful to people's health.
Drinking silver solution and similar so-called
colloidal silver can make it so your body
doesn't properly absorb antibiotics and other
medications.
They can start to turn your skin.
Sort of a bluish gray.
It's bad.
Stop saying it cures Corona virus.
I have another one for you today and it just
so happens to be another Christian lunatic.
This one's Kenneth Copeland.
Healing people of the virus through the TV.
Kenneth Copeland, if you're not familiar with
them, is this 83 year old televangelist worth
a reported 760 million dollars thanks to a
very successful multi-decade grift that he's
been running and he has used his grift to
put fund private jets to fund a very lavish
lifestyle.
And here he is visibly sort of sweaty with
some kind of, I'm sure, if special healing
water on his hand, healing his viewers, mostly
old folks who are at risk through the TV during
a very, quote, special report called Standing
Against Corona Virus.
We need vaccines, we need anti-virals.
We need actual medical treatments.
Standing against Corona virus with prayer
through the TV is not what we need, but that's
what he's offering.
Put your hand on that television.
Yes.
Thank you, Jesus.
Thank you, Lord Jesus.
He received your healing?
Yes.
Now.
Say it, I'll take it, I'll take it.
I have it, I have.
It's mine.
Thank you and praise you for it.
Yes.
And I forgive if I have aught against any.
Forgive you.
And I praise you that I'm well and whole praise
you that I'm with you according to the word
of God.
Returning to the word of.
Heal.
Yes.
And I consider not my own body.
Yes, yes.
But I consider not symptoms in my body.
I consider no symptoms, but only that which
God has promised me.
Not only that, what the word has said that
by his stripes I was healed.
And by his stripes I am healed now.
I'm not the sheik trying to get healed.
I'm the healed.
And the devil is trying to give me the flu
through or whatever else kind of thing he's
trying.
Yeah.
Heal an oil.
Yes.
In a sweet naming conventions that go.
People are more likely to die if they believe
that this works because they are more at risk
of dying if they get coronavirus, because
these are older audiences that watch this
nonsense.
This should be illegal, but it's not.
He makes gobs of money with this nonsense.
And I hate to break it to you, but it's not
just lunatic Christian televangelists that
are doing this.
Trump has been doing it.
Rush Limbaugh has been doing it.
Fox and Friends has been doing it.
Trump tweeted the day before yesterday, a
couple days ago, in his infinite orange wisdom
and leadership, quote, Today is a national
day of prayer.
God bless everyone.
What we need is a day of testing.
Not a day of prayer.
We need a day of procuring ventilators, not
blessings.
That we need people to stay home, not to go
to churches.
And if we're going to pray for anything, it
should be for a competent person to take over
dealing with this pandemic crisis.
And of course, remember, once you bring God
into it.
The obvious question is follow.
This is just up to God.
Why didn't God stop Corona virus?
Why did God allow or create Corona virus?
Wouldn't it be simpler, easier, better?
Instead of creating or allowing Corona virus
and then waiting for people to pray enough
for God to stop it?
Why not just skip Corona virus altogether?
Oh, well, but David.
David.
God works in mysterious ways.
Maybe we haven't been praying hard enough.
Right.
We're done, folks.
As a society, if this is what we're counting
on.
Insert bogus lunatic talking point here.
This stuff is truly vile.
It should be illegal.